I was 12 years old when I got my first
modem 1200 board is compatible and
started getting online and not the
Internet online local BBS's
at around the same time yuppies were
sporting the first brick sized mobile
phones as the first gsm networks started
rolling out fast forward less than 17
years to 2007 and the iPhone launches
followed less than a year by Android and
almost overnight we've come to expect
the world's information in the palm of
our hands just six years after the first
Android phone launched its powering
everything from phones to tablets
watches TVs and cars so where do we go
next the most obvious answer is enabling
the same handheld cloud connected
computing platform to the next five
billion people as Hardware becomes
cheaper and more powerful more of the
world's population will be able to get
internet connected computers and the
smart phone is going to be what makes it
possible to facilitate this we're seeing
new approaches to getting online mesh
networks white spaces or even Google's
Project loon will hopefully soon see
ubiquitous worldwide Internet
connectivity become a reality
at the same time smart phones will start
to disappear in the same way that we
don't think of computers as computers
once they become part of our dishwashers
cars or TVs we'll stop thinking of
mobiles as such when they disappear into
our watches and white goods we'll come
to expect that anything that can be
improved through the incorporation of a
wireless internet connection will simply
have one but that to happen we need to
find more creative ways to interact with
computers than using mice keyboards and
touchscreens I can already pick up my
phone or with my wrist address Google
and perform searches send texts or email
set alarms or take notes without having
to touch a screen or keyboard screens
themselves have become so sharp that
their pixel densities aren't perceptible
to the human eye and the team of Google
X are building contact lenses capable of
measuring blood sugar levels speaking of
sensors not only can I control my phone
by putting it either face up or face
down it has a battery of sensors similar
to an ages class warship light meters
temperature gauges barometers gyroscopes
all of which can be used to replace text
entry or automate processes
wearables cars and thermostats
introduced even more possibilities for
sensors connect all of that to the cloud
and the possibilities are endless future
of Android isn't a more powerful phone
operating system it's as the brains
behind invisible ubiquitous cloud
connected computing so the skills we
learn today to build cool apps are the
same skills we'll use tomorrow to
control everything around us we've taken
the first step into that future I can't
wait to see what you do next